With his eye-catching good
looks and magnetic aura,
it’s no surprise why Jason Momoa has charmed so
many film and television viewers. He achieved
stupendous silver screen success by playing
Aquaman in the blockbuster of the same name,
which is the second-highest-grossing DC Extended
Universe movie as of the making of this video.
Momoa also gained acclaim for his performance as
the charismatic Duncan Idaho in the 2021 sci-fi
epic "Dune." He will portray the Protector of the
Deep for the second time in "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom," which Momoa praised for being more
lighthearted than its darker DCEU counterparts.
Before he was a big box office draw,
Momoa was best known for his role on
TV's preeminent fantasy show. He appeared as
the menacing and memorable Dothraki leader
Khal Drogo during the first season and one
episode of the second season of "Game of Thrones."
In the series premiere "Winter is Coming,"
Drogo enters an arranged marriage with
Daenerys Targaryen, played by Emilia Clarke.
The two eventually fall in love, but their
relationship is marred in the beginning
by disturbing non-consensual sex acts.
While filming these graphic and
disagreeable so-called love scenes,
Momoa did everything in his power to
make his co-star comfortable. Since
he was so considerate towards her, Clarke has
publicly praised Momoa for his on-set behavior.
"Game of Thrones" has been heralded as one of the
greatest shows of all time, but that adulation
has not shielded it from criticism. Viewers and
critics have called out the HBO series for its
gratuitous sex and nudity. Emilia Clarke appeared
in numerous nude scenes in the first season
of "Game of Thrones," oftentimes without any
clear plot-related reason to justify the stunt.
Since the actress was 23 with only
a few acting credits to her name,
she was understandably uneasy not wearing clothes
on set. To make matters worse, Clarke's first
intimate scene on "Game of Thrones" involved her
character being sexually assaulted by her husband.
While filming the upsetting scene with her
castmate, Jason Momoa, he did his best to make her
feel at ease and protected, which is what every
young actor deserves from their scene partners.
Clarke told the "Armchair Expert" podcast
that Momoa "took care of her" and "was so
kind and considerate" toward her. She added
that he demanded the crew give her a robe to
cover up and keep warm between takes. Clarke's
account of Momoa's on-set behavior proves what
a warmhearted and thoughtful performer he is.
It's a personality trait that shines through,
even when he's playing a ruthless
character like the Dothraki khal.
Jason Momoa's sweet and supportive behavior
towards Emilia Clarke extended beyond their
intimate scenes. The "Aquaman" actor was
incredibly concerned about his "GOT" co-star's
health. In a beautifully candid and courageous
essay in The New Yorker, Clarke opened up
about her potentially fatal brain aneurysms.
The same year "Game of Thrones" premiered,
she experienced a subarachnoid hemorrhage. Clarke
also had an operation to treat a life-threatening
brain bleed caused by a second aneurysm
two years after the first one ruptured.
When Entertainment Tonight asked Momoa about
Clarke's health issues, he revealed he had,
quote, "kind of been a part of that
whole situation for a very long time." He
added that he was "trying to find the right
way to come out and help" after Clarke's
health scares. Momoa said he was sad because the
world "almost lost her numerous times." He also
emphasized that he loves the Mother of Dragons
portrayer and that she will do great things.
"It's very sad, because we almost
lost her numerous times. So,
I love her to bits and she's here and
she's going to do great things with it."
It is clear the former on-screen spouses share
a profound emotional bond. They remain close
about a decade after they met on the "GOT"
set. According to Entertainment Weekly,
Momoa and Clarke reunited in August 2021
at David Benioff's birthday party. They
took adorable photos together, one of which
Momoa posted on Instagram with the caption,
"MOON OF MY LIFE. you are
wonderful love u forever."
If you or anyone you know has
been a victim of sexual assault,
help is available. Visit the Rape, Abuse &
Incest National Network website or contact
RAINN's National Helpline
at 1-800-656-HOPE (4673).